Yle Areena.
Etä kelta sirkku ei syö lintulaualta, se syö maasta.
Etä siinäpäs tää on teille pulmaa kerrakseen,
jos te ootta sitä mieltä, että pitää aina siivota kaikki lintulauvan alta,
ni kyllä kelta sirkkujen pitää syyä niinku ne syö,
ne ei alistu kiipeelle lintulauolle, niinku en minäkää kyllä alistu aivan kaikkeen, juoksutukseen.
Nä oa jo sen verran iäkäs, maan maahinen. Kiitos teille.
Vai ei kelta sirkut suostu syömään kuin maasta?
Oma lintutuntemusku valitettavasti rajoittuu siihen, että älä syö muikkuja lokkien lähellä,
ja aihe rupesi vähän kiinnostamaan, niin minä laitoin viestiä aiheesta BirdLife Suomeen.
Sieltä viestinnästä Jukka Hintikka vastasi, että totta, kelta sirkku se hyvin mielellään ruokailee maassa,
mutta se kelta sirkku on hyvä löytämään muiden lintujen heittelemät murut,
joten varsinaista maahan ruokkimista ei kannata tehdä, koska se kyllä houkuttelee niitä rottia paikalle.
Ja siinä on myös se riski, että ruoka voi joutua kosketuksiin lintujen ulosteiden kanssa,
mikä taas voi johtaa tautien leviämiseen.
Kaura lyhde on kuulema siitä mukava, viriteltävä, että sen saa sidottua irti maasta,
esimerkiksi pensaan runkoon tai oksaan niin, että kelta sirkku pystyy ruokailemaan oksalla.
Se on kansanradio ja Lasse Olkinora tässä tervehdys.
Tämänkertaisen jakson lintuihin liittyvät asiat, ne on nyt käsitelty,
mutta paljon muuta riittää, Suomen hiihtäjien tasosta Mikkelin takseihin ja lomavinkkejäkin kuullaan,
Kreikan saaristoja kannattaa kuulemaa ihmisen vältellä.
Nyt seuraavaksi vuoroon kaikenlaista, mitä on, televisiosta nähty ja radiosta kuultu.
Komentoida, et olis joku tolkku, ei muuta, mummeli.
No hei, tääl o yks musiikkikuuntelija.
Heti aamusta ruvetaan soittaa niitä samoja naaraskissojen maukuntaa,
joka helvetin aamu, ku silmät avaa.
Et eikö maalmassa oo paljo ihania kappaleita, mutta näit, oi herraiest, oi niitä aikoja,
ku sai kuunnella niitä vanhoja hyviä, 70-80-luvun biisejä.
Hei, hei.
No, hyvää huomenta, täällä soittelee Jats radion ystävä.
Lähdinpä soittelemaan ihan kansan radioon, kun huomasin harmikseni,
että, nyt, vuoden vaihduttua, Yleradio yhdellä on supistettu Jatsin tarjontaa.
Ennen sunnuntaisin tuli kolmen tunnin kiva setti.
Nyt sitten tarjonta onkin supistettu kahteen tuntiin ihan tulevilla kaikilla,
Ainakin nähtävissä olevilla ohjelmapaikoilla, tämä harmittaa suuresti.
Miksi näin on tehty, en tiedä, onko kyseessä nyt sitten säästötoimet,
mutta, joka tapauksessa, harmittaa suuresti. Kiitos.
No, uutisista kuulii, jotta nyt on keksitty ratkaasu tähän nuorteen peukkuongelmahan.
Kuolema, annetahan viidenkymmenen euron lahjakortti tai ilimaisia hampurilaskuponkia.
Jos pääsee huumeesta erohan.
Voi, kiesus, sanon minä, kyllä ollahan kaukana torellisuudesta.
Juurisyihin pitäis tarttua, niitten nuorten kotia pitää mennä,
ja ensimmäin pitäis tutkia se, jotta, onko vanhemmat pilettäjä vanhempia.
Se, joka perjantai ja lauantai, ollaan tillin talliin.
Työryhmä, laittaa siihen ja käydä kaikki perheet, lapsiperheet läpi,
joona on vääkeongelmaa, jotta, tätä mieltä minä oon. Kiitos.
Kuulin ja luin telkkarista, kuinka postijakelukeskuksesta Helsingistä vähennetään 170 henkilöä.
Nyt kyllä huolestutta, että kulkeako postikohtaa enää ollenkaan mihinkään.
Kaandoin kesti tuota sysmästä Lahteen.
Kirje, mennä peräti kaksi vuotta, kolme kuukautta, yhdeksantoista päivää.
Eli, jos siellä jakelulinjoilla tai siellä ei ole yhtään ihmiskäsiä töissä,
ni, jos linjat ja joku paketti tai kirje tai joku tippuu lattialle, ni kuka niistä nostaa.
Nyt sitten tuntuu, että kaikki on kohta niin digi, digi, digi, ettei enää kirjetäkään voi lähteä.
Vielä muutenkin noi työllisyysluvut on noi huippu lukeriset.
Nyt ollaan maailman parhaita, jossain asiassa edes.
Ei tässä muuta ku hyvät päivät jatkut vaan kaikille, että moikka moi.
Ylekin muuten uutisoi aiheesta, Helsingin Postin lajittelukeskuksesta on tarkoitus vähentää 79 työntekijää,
ihan sellainen pieni välihuomautus.
Mutta työttömyydestä tullut paljon puheluita menneen viikon aikana,
kuten myös sähkön hintaan ja tuotantoon liittyen.
Taitavat olla ihan viikon soitetuimmat aiheet.
No nii, Maulo Voutilainen, Jyväskylän, Kelan eläkeläinen,
studiopankaa soimaan, morilaisten marssi,
sillä marraskuun tilanteen mukaan Suomi on,
Euroopan johtava työttömyysvaltio on mennyt viime marraskuussa tilaston mukaan.
Espanjan ohi, tämä on vaatinut pitkän aheruksen ja innovaatioiden ja huonontumisen
ja tämän yhteisen laarin haperoitumisen,
ja tässä tulee monille höperöityminen, kun tulee tätä pikää aina vaan lisää,
mutta hyvää ja jousilasta sunnuntain jaskoa kaikille kiitollisille koulutelijoille.
Olet maa, me armain Suomen maa, rysirantaan.
Ihmetteleen vaan komasti, kun tuo sähkön tuotantoni ja kulutus on eri tasolla.
Kun sanottiin silloin, kun alokuloto kolmosta tehti,
että kun taasuahan valammista, sähkö on vientii asti,
niin ehty viety pätkeekä, eikä riitä omaan käyttänyntä.
Koko ajan pitää vain tuuva virosta ja ruotsista,
mistä ihmestä sitä tuuvankkani.
Kummalisi puu pätä nanna, arvioijata ja nalaskia.
Tämä on minun miehi, ei munka, ei.
Kylmän kammo täällä soittoa, kun on tämmösiä pakkasia,
niin muistuu mieleen joittenkin ihmisryhmien puheet
tästä ilmaston lämpenemisestä.
Ja tuota, ehkä keskimääräinen, vuotuinen lämpötila nouseeekin,
mutta kyllä sillä on nyt hämätty paljon.
Meit on viety tämmösiä varmuuslämpölaitteita,
fossiiliset ölylaitteet, kaikki, ei niitä oo edes varalla enää kellää,
se on pelkkää sähköä kaikki.
Porukka, joka täällä mellastaa tämän ilmaston lämpenemisen kanssa,
niin sillä ei oo mitä vastuuta.
Tää Suomi on Pohjoinen maa,
ja tää voi olla tämmösiä talvia koska tahansa.
Ja me ollaan katastrofissa sen jälkeen, kun tuo sähkö pettää.
Mitään varalämmitystä ei ole.
Täällähän vihapuheistani rangaistaa, ja valheista rangaistaa, ja…
Mut Paskan puhumisesta ei näköjään saa minkälaista rangaistusta,
vaikka tuolla Arkadianmäellä, niin sitä suoletaan.
Hyvä päivä, onpa ilo kuulla, palioko sähköä nytten on kulunut.
Sehän tulee vielä nousemaan, vaikka kuinka paljon.
Tehän olette niitä keskuksia, anpaneet tänne Suomeen tulla,
Muut maat niitä ei huoli.
Kansa maksaa Suomessa kaiken.
Kyllä se on kumma juttu, siis törkeetä touhua.
Eehä se muuten ois noussu, eikä muuten sitä laitettu, niinkun on.
Kyllä on niin älyväinen maa tämä, ja poliitikkojen, et ei järkeä oo missään.
Hyvä, että Trumpies toimii ja vetelee. Hyvää päiväjatkoa.
Meitä odottaa seuraavaksi, tavalla tai toisella, autoiluun liittyvät viestit.
Sitä ennen yksi viesti, jonka on allekirjoittanut Jartsev tasa-arvoinen.
Kolmastoista ensimmäistä oli Helsingin Sanomissa mielipidekirjoitus,
lapselle kuuluu äidin sukunimi.
No, siihen en ota kantaa, koska lienee aika marginaalinen kysymys,
sen sijaan olen sitä mieltä, että äidille kuuluu äidin sukunimi.
Kun naiset ovat hyvinkin herkillä kaikenlaisten tasa-arvokysymysten osalta,
niin en ole voinut pitkiin aikoihin kuin ihmetellä sitä,
että nainen avioiduttuaan useimmiten luopuu täysin omasta identiteetistään.
Nainen joko ottaa miehen nimen tai ottaa kaksiosaisen sukunimen,
joka on suorastaan absurdia.
On se myös järjetön byrokratia vyyhti tehdä tällaisia identiteetin kadotustemppuja.
Minä en miehenä ikinä muuttaisi sukunimeäni missään tilanteessa.
Naiset, älkää tehkö tällaisia ratkaisuja suoraan tasa-arvon perusteita vastaan.
Kyllä se itsetunto löytyy, kun pitää päänsä.
No, timpa tätä Itä-Helsingistä.
Katteli uutisia tässä juuria.
Jotenkin taas tämä romutusparkki on vanhoista autoista jotain,
ja sähköautoihin, et saat jotakin hyötyä.
Mä oon vähän sitä mieltä, et sähköautot on tullu vähän turhan nopee,
niitähän räjähtenee tuolla parkkihalleissa, akkuja, riipadaapa,
en mä ets tiedä, miten se menee, mutta niiden massa on niin paljon isompi, et tiät ei kestä niitä,
ja sitten, ku kaikki on, sähtöautoja, et, tää on vähän semmoista vihreinen piperrystä, vaan, tää on mun mielipide.
Mutta mukavaa alku, vai oks tämän loppu talveen, toivottavasti moi.
Kimmo tästä alajirviltä vaan terveen.
Ajokorttia varten lähin tuotani laittamaan niiku lääkärin todistustani.
Eihän sitä saa enää mistää niiku kunnalliselta hommalta, eikä mitää,
niiku siei menee viis minuuttia noja aikaa ni.
Nyt, nyt, nyt sitten tuotani, laitetaan sitten tämän yksityiseltani.
Sata kaeksankymppiä.
Sata kaeksankyt euroa maksaa nyt sitten tuotani yksityisellä tämä homma,
että kyllä se on hyvää politiikkojäristelmää, tämä homma, että.
Laitetaan, laitetaan sitten tällainen köyhä maksamaa vielä hirveitä summia tämmöset niiku,
ihan tämmöset niiku, nääksää tai kuuleksää, vaiksa mitää nää.
Ei ne kyllä, ne politikot nii nää, eikä ni kuule, ei yhtää.
Eiks ne oo oikeita lääkäreitä ne aluelääkärillä, ku se ei enää käy ajokortin uusintaan, se terveyskeskuksen lääkärillä osunto.
Mitä varten ne siellä sitten on, jos se ei, ne oo, eiks ne ooka lääkäreitä.
Ja sit toine asia, että se voisi kyllä muuttaa nii, että se 70 vuotta muuttuis vaikka 75 vuotta,
nii ku se ajokortti minää vanheks, tai vaikka 80.
Tää meni rahastukseks yksityiselle, mut tuli yölle tutulle maksaa melkei 500, ku se uusi korttinsa,
että tämmönenki pelleeli tehtiin, että ei mulla tässä muuta, että hoitetaan jaksaan, kiitos, hei.
Kansanradiotervehdys.
Tervehdys, Pekka, no ponen täällä. Mitä Mikkelistä soittelee?
Mikkelistä soittelee, Pekka.
Tota, no sitä korttitaksilista on mulle juttuja, tota, ette, kun on myöhässä aina melekkit.
Saanko kysyä, että mitä kautta sen kortin?
Ei minä kelata sitä, et saanut, tuota, se o kaupungin juttuja se olet.
Okei, kaupungilta sellainen juttuja, ne taksit sen kautta, kun tilani, ovat aina myöhässä.
Joo, kolme kertaa tunnin myöhässä olleet, ja sitten tuota, kolme varkkia yhäkärää.
Näin Mikkelissä siis. Siinähän ihminen myöhästyy, myöhästyy sovituista menoista, kun on noin myöhässä.
Kyllä, jaa.
Ootko sinne, asiakaspalvelu ottanut yhteyttä, mitä sanovat sieltä?
No, en oo vielä sinne ottana, pitää sinne soittaa, omen.
Kannattaa soittaa ja sanoa, että mikä, mikä juttu, että pitääkö se rueta tilaamaan aina tuntia aikaisemmin, ku mitä olis tarvis lähteä?
Nii, minä olet, se ne ottaa liikkaa kyyttiä, se keskus, et näissä pystyisit läämaa niitä.
Niii.
Se kii voidaan oo syynä.
En tiedä, ehkä sitä pitää sinne asiakaspalveluun soittaa, ja pikkasen tentata, että miksi ollut näin myöhässä.
Joo, mutta vähän täsmällisyyttä siihen hommaan, semmoinen kelpais kyllä.
Mutta hyvä, kun soitit aiheesta.
Kiitos paljon.
Moi.
Meille saapunut tänne kansanradiojuuri yksi kirje, joka on päivätty jo kuudes tammikuuta, sen takia tässä kirjeessä käsitellään aiemmin kansanradiossa puhututta nutta aihetta.
Sanotaan nyt sitten vaikka, että parempi myöhään, kun ei milloinkaan.
Kansanradiolle.
Joitakin aikoja sitten kansanradioon soitti nishenkilö, joka kovasti paheksui parrakkaita toimittajia.
Rohkenen olla täysin eri mieltä.
Parrakas mies on komea ja miehekäs.
Erityisesti suosikkejani ovat esimerkiksi Mikko Hirvonen ja Ilkka Lahti.
Itse olen jo niin vanha leskirouva, että miestä ei tule minun makuuhuoneeseen kuin television kautta, joten kiitos siitä.
Pusu ilman viiksiä on kuin muna ilman suolaa.
Terveisin Rauha.
No, täällä Savolainen pakana.
Minua huviitti, ku kansanradioon soitti herrasmies, jota ärsytti se, että joulu on pilalla, koska ei juhlita enää Kristusta, vaan joulupukkia, sitä Coca-Cola-pukkia.
Hänelle voisin sanoa, että todennäköisesti ei oo mitään todisteita siitä, että Jeesus ois syntynyt silloin 24. päivän joulukuuta Itäasiassa siihen aikaan, Euroopassa varsinkin keltiton tuhansia vuosia sitten viettänyt tämmöstä talvipäivän sesoksen juhlaa, ja se on todennäköisesti ollut myös täällä Itämeren suomalaisilla kihemolla jonkulosta tappaa juhlista, sitä valoon paluuta ja sitä päivän piteenemistä.
Kaikki joulukuusetynne muutti, nii ne oo ihan pakaanalista perinnettä niinku kristittyjen näkökulmasta.
Sitten mainitti Halloweeni, onhan meillekki ollut keikrimit, missä silloin on muistettu kaikkia suvuesii vanahempia ja tämmösiä.
Nykyysihän kirkko on lätkäytänyt siihen nii pyhään päivä, jossa sitten toistetaan näitä samoja tapakaanalisia tapoja viiään noita kynttilöitä haavoille, ja muistellaan suvua vanahempia.
Elikkä, jos korpeaa esikristillinen vaikutus omassa uskonnossa, nii kannattaa ottaa yhteyttä sinne omaan kirkon peämaijia, ja keskustella, että oisko pitänyt keksiä kuitenki jotai omaa.
Kaitsoi Raumalta, soitteli, ikse nyt siihen, kansanradio voisi tämmöseä oitoa, että Putin ja Trump soittoa voisi lopettaa.
Ei me sillä mitä voi, ne touhu, mitä touhu, nii.
Nyt muutama, muutami muut juttuja on kivaa kuunelmaa, kyllä se on niinku, se on ne joutavaa, turha löpsäytys niistku.
Vois laittaa piene estoa nyt, niistä ei tarvitsi kuunneaa.
Tuota, rupeaisi soittelemaan, kun minä sinne aina silloin tällö lähetään niitä viestiä, vaan ei sinne näy menevän kuin tämmönen, joka on Suomesta tyypillistä, että pitää olla kaikesta samaa mieltä.
Jotakin voi aina joskus sanoa, mutta niinku tämä rumppi, mitä tekee, mitä lystää, nii sitä niinku kestä arvostella, eikä niitä Suomen herroja, ne on nuollee persettisen eessä, että.
Anteeksi, kansanradiossa ei mene läpi Trumpin ja Suomen herrojen kritisointi.
Joo, ei mene, ku se ennehähän Rumpia saa haakua, kuin paljon vaan, ku sitä tuli tämmönen suuri Jumala, niin sitä pitää Suomen olla kaikki samman, et niinku yleisradiossa niinku kaikissa muussakin tästä ei saa sanoa, mutta Venäjä voi voittia, sitähän voi voittia, vaikka lähettää sinne ohjuksia, ni semmoiset menee läpi, kyllä, mutta ei tämmöstä asialista arvostelua, mitään sitä nykyisestä poliitikasta, mitään tehdään tuolla.
Mutta nythän on sulla mahdollisuus, joten kerro, mitä kritiikkiä Trumpin suuntaan haluat lähtää?
No sitä, että tota, ei pitäisi niinku mielistellä sitä niinku se tekee nämä Euroopan maat, että sitä pitää panna vastaan, ketä Venäjän piti puuttuva, ku hyöksisi, ni sitä pitää poikotoja, nyt tietysti samaan se meni vallottaa Venezuela sieltä, ja ottaa kaiken vallan, ja rahat suoraan tunnusta, että öljyvää, tässä tultii hakeemaan ja kaikkea muuta, niin joka paikka se on menossa, tota, Irlandia ja muuta omistaa, mistä tulee rahha, että ei nämä, miksi nyt ei tämä NATO, Euroopan maat puhuu?
Nä vaan mielistelee sitä, ja antaa tehä mitä vaan, ja kohtahan se tosiaan hyökkää, niinku se aikoo hyökkää kaikkiin maihin, mutta täällä ollaan hiljaa, ja nöyristellää vaan, että, missahan se tehdään näe.
Mutta Putini, jos tekee jotakin, tai täällä tehdään jotakin, se on Putini tehnyt, tämä räijöksi, tämä on nyt se sähköpoikisen teke, kun Putini on tehnyt näe.
Tätä, sitä on kyllä, näitä virsiä, kyllä kuuluu aivan riittävästi. Se on nämä herrojen tapa, että pitää kumarttaa toisia ja nuoleskella. Tämähän se on, näin se menee tässä tietoisvälineessäkin, että ei siellä oo mittaa oikeutaa, monella ihmeellä saa mittaa kantoja läpi.
Mutta nythän sinä juuri sait läpi.
Saihan minä, mutta menneekö siellä läpi sitä, tuleeko sitä jottaa, vaan tuleeko sitä taas, että se on, joo.
Katotaan viikon päästä vielä, mutta ei näet paljon kannata kuunnella, se tätä menoa jakkuu, tämä yksipuolinen ylistys täällä. Kiitos, hei.
Kyös tikeuduuta päivää. On aika kiittää kansanradiossa, kun ihmiset ei osaa muuta kuin moittia.
Olin jouluntienossa sairaalan ovaassa yksitoista vuodotautta. Hoito oli yleillisen, hyvää, kertakaikkiaan ammattitaitoista.
Lääkärit ja hoitajat, hoitajat oli iloisia, hymyilivät. Ja hoito oli hyvä, ja minä paranin. Minä kiitän sairaalan ovaa tämmöisestä palvelusta.
Se on hienoa, Suomessa on terveydenhoito todella hyvällä tasolla. Ja sitä kannattaa kunnioittaa. Kiitoksia paljon.
No, kuulla paa, ei mulla mitään muuta, kun tuli vaan mieleen tuossa kansanradiota kuunillessa ja tuossa kauppareisuilta, kun palasin kotiin ja näin miettimään tätä.
Tuli äitini, kainuulaisen, edesmennen, äitivainaani lauseen mielen, että antaa hevosten surras silloin isompi pää ja pidemmät silmäriipset.
Antaa hevosten surras silloin isompi pää ja pidemmät silmäriipset.
Joo, ja kainuulaiset oli piteemmät silmäriipset.
Törmäsin entiseen vuosikymmenen takaisen työkaverin, vanhempaa rouvaa, joka oli rollattorilla liikkeellä ja alettiin juttelemaan ja kysei, mitä kuuluu.
Mummeli pilahti itkuun, sanoo, että kuhan on niin väsynyt, että ku täällä kaupassakin kaikki tulee valittamaan ja valittamaan ja sairauksia ja vaivojaan kertomaan, että hän ei jaksa.
Ja totesin itseni ku mielessäni aivan samaan, että yleensä ne ihmiset, jotka haluat kuunnella ja myötä elää, niin ne kuormittuu sitten tässä valivalivirreissä, että virsien kuuntelussa.
Nä on ihan, se on aivan loputon suopun, että valituksia alkaa kuuntelee.
Niin, pitää muistaa myös omat rajat ja omien voimien mukaan mennä, kyllä.
Joo, ne valitusvirret ei lopu koskaan maailmassa, ja sit, joka haluaa auttaa, niin kyllä helposti uupuu tässä toisen auttamisessa, koska itsekin olen kokenut, että ei heillä ole joku mitään kunnialtusta, oli sulla yö tai päivä tai vapaa päivä tai pyhä päivä, niin sieltä tulvimalla tulee niitä avun.
Pyyntöjä, ja hyvin yleisesti on, että he eivät haluaisi itse teidän mitään, vaan antaa valmit ohjeet.
Hyvä muistutus siitä, että muistaa myös ihminen ajatella itseään.
Joo, että täytyy valita itse paikkansa siinä sopaassa, että onko kauhan varreessa vai sitten rosinona mukana killumassa siellä sekahedelmäkeidossa.
Erittäin totta, erittäin totta.
Joo, että toivoisi ihmisille semmoista mieltä, että voisinko minä tehdä tälle asialle jotakin, jostaakin minä valitan.
Ja ei kuormittaa lähimmäisiä liikaa tällä toisilla, joka jolle valittaa, hänellä voi olla paljon huonommin asiat kuin sillä, joka valittaa.
Minä kiitän paljon, kun soitit tänne, oli mukava jutella. Kiitos. Moi.
Hei hei.
Se, se on monen asian kohdalla tuo tasapainottaminen haastava harrastus, että osaa juuri oikealla kohtuudella.
Esimerkiksi vaikka tuo äskeinen, koska kyllähän ihmisen pitää murheensa ilmaista, mutta ettei sillä sitten kuormita toista, ja sekin tietysti olisi hyvä taito sanoa, että nyt ei valitettavasti pysty ottamaan enää vastaan,
mutta sitä myös niin helposti pelkää, että kutsutaan tylyksi.
Mikä se sitten on tuossa asiassa juuri se kultainen keskitie, niin joku viisaampi voi siihen vastata, myös seuraaviin kysymyksiin voi vastata, jos vastausta löytyy.
Tosin osa näistä kysymyksistä taitaa kyllä olla luonteeltaan vähän enemmän kommentteja.
Se on aivan mieletöntä, se uusintojen määrä.
Ja onko niin, että kaikki ne rippuset rahat, mitä säästyy muka, menee johtajille? kysyy kansalainen.
Täällä Kari kotkastuu. Nyt kun hän meni ratiastui, toi hetka olin alioidaamaan, niin koskast hää perikistä.
No hei, kämin tuossa Tukholmassa ja ihmettelin siellä niitä hintoja, kuinka paljon ne on alempiako Suomessa.
Ki attekissani sama ruokakauppa ja sitten nämä ravintolaruuat, niin ne on semmoinen kolme nelvitarosettia, joka on salaventieko Suomessa.
Tieste, mikä Suomessa tekenee, niin hirveen kalliise.
Sitten näistä juutteli yhen kanssa, jonka on tuntenu jo pitkään, niin hän saa attekkiin, ku hän on pieneläkeläinen.
Sosialilta semmoisen maksusitoumuksen, että hän saa lääkkeet, hänellä jää se eläkesuunnilleen, ruokaa ja elämiseen.
Et miten meillä Suomessa tuota, ei ihme, että on nämä pieneläkeläiset ja, jotka elää työttömyyskorvauksilla tämmösen, niin velka on tuneet ava hirveesti.
No, ulosotossa valtavat määrät. Ni tuota, ei tämmönen poli, oikeistolainen politiikka, missä ei ihmisillä oo kunnuna ruokaa, rahaa.
Ni, ne vielä ajetaan sitten tommoseen velkävankeuteen, ulosottoa ja vaikka mihin, vaikka jonkulainen uusi systeemi, kyllä pitäis näille vanhoille naisille ja miehille luoda, että he saa attekista lääkkiä.
On tää niin herviä, tuota, touhua, että en mä käsitä tätä, mihin Suomi o ajaltuu. Ei muuta, kiitos.
Kansanradiotervehdys.
Hyvää päivää.
Päivää.
Täällä, varsinä Suomesta, Petri soittelee.
Mitä kuuluu Petri juuri tänä suunnuntaina?
No, lepäili tässä sängylä ja, tää oli vaan kannata.
Eli juuri niiku sunnuntain pitääki.
Kyllä.
Mutta joku asia ehkä vähän nostattaa pulssia, kun soitit Kansanradio.
Kyllä nostattaa, tää edisvarmasti harrastukset niiku, et ei oo niiku riittävästi harrastuksiä edisvarmaisille.
Se oli siis kunnan, kaupungin järjestämänä.
Nii, et tuntuu, et joitäkin harrastuksiä on, mutta ei niinku riittävästi.
Et säis niiku tutustuttuu niiku uusin ystäviin, ja kaikki tämmöstä mulkaa, ja koimantaa ystävää, ja.
Et se sellaista yhteisöllisuutta ja muita ihmisiä kaipaa.
Nii, ja seuraa, ja. Et oli se kuuluu lenkiseuraa, myös, ja.
Sais keskustelemaan joku kavarikas renkin aikana, ja sit sais niiku käydä jossain, niiku kahvilla, myös, ja niin edespäin.
Nii, mihikäs sitä voisi sitten laittaa ilmotuksen, että lenkki ja kahvi seuraa, mutta ihan vaan siis niiku täysin ystäväpohjalta.
Nii, ja suurimmiten samaa ikäistä seuraa vielä, et ei liian nuori tai liian vanha.
Hetkinen, mitäs kautta tuommoista muuten lenkki kahviseuraa ja ihan täysin ystäväpohjalta, mistäs kautta sellaista lähdetään hakemaan?
Nii, se on hyvä kysymys, kuule.
Mullakin löydyt ihan tyhjää.
Tuo oli hyvä kysymys, ja enpä osaa itse vastata siihen, että mitä kautta hakee vaikkapa lenkkeilyseuraa.
Toivon, ettei oo kuulolla joku ihminen, joka osaisi tässä kerrata.
Tältö tarjo katta, joku voisi ratkaista tämän.
No nii just, hyvä ku soitit tänne.
Joo, tässä on päskinä portavaksi se kollekki.
Nii, hei, kiitos todella paljon, ku soitit, minä toivotan, Leppo saa sunnu.
Sitä se varsenee toimituksia.
Kiitos paljon, kiitos.
Tepalta on tullut tällainen ehdotus tai vinkki, että olympialaisiin maalialueelle voisi järjestää jonkun tyypin,
joka antaisi hiihtäjille pyyhkeen, paperia tai vastaavaa, johon voisivat pyyhkiä ne naamasta roikkuvat limat.
Niitä on todella vasten mielistä katsoa, terveisiin teepaa.
Ja tämänkertainen jakso päättyykin erilaisiin vinkkeihin.
Sitä ennen minä muistan kertoa meidän yhteystiedot, joita en ole vielä kertaakaan unohtanut,
ja sehän on tällaiselle erittäin hajamieliselle ihmiselle suuri voitto ja ylpeyden aihe.
Whatsappitse, jos haluaa lähestyä, niin 044 55 154 64.
Sähköpostit osoitteeseen kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Ja käsinkirjoitettut kirjeet, kortit, kansanradio, PL 79 00 00 24, yleisaradio.
Ja tietysti se meidän vastaaja on 08 00 154 64.
Suunnuntaina lähetyksen jälkeen kolmen tunnin ajan paikalla ihmis vastaaja tällä viikolla,
juuri nyt äänessä oleva, soita ihmeessä pistetään maailmaa mallilleen.
Lasse Olkinoira toivottaa nyt oikein hyvää pakkaspäiväväviettoa,
eli vilttiä päälle ja villasukkaa jalkaan.
Digiturvalisuus, eli Pekko Latva, tätä terve, koko Suomi.
Digiturvalisuudesta haluaisin puhua tämmöstä asiaa,
että älkää koskaan avaatko linkkiä, nikun tekstiviestissä, sähköpostissa,
tai johonkin on tullu vaikka sähköpostiin tai tekstiviestii linkki,
ni älkää koskaan avaatko linkkiä, jos ette tiedä vastaajan tietoja.
Vikiturvalisuus on ehdottomasti tärkeintä nykyajasta. Moi?
Sulo, tässä, hei. Suomen urheilu ois ihan toisella tasolla,
ois kaikki hiihtojoukkuet siirryttäisiin Norjaa valmennattelyksi.
Samoin, muu yleisurheilu ois toisella tasolla,
kun Suomen valmenteet valmenteet eivät tässä pereudu niin hyvin asioihin kuin Norjassa.
Kannastaa miettiä, hei.
Vulsan aika on parhaillaan meneillään,
mutta koronan jälkeisestä ajasta on unohtunut aivan ilmiselvästi se yskimisetiketti.
Yskitään ihan, kuinka sattuu, myrkin kärkeen avokämmenen,
mut ei vahingossakaan tai harvemminkin hihan, niin kuin silloin koronan aikana opetettiin,
joka varmasti auttais aika paljon tartuntoja.
Kansanradio ois tietysti yksi avainen paikka, mistä vois tätä muistutella välillä.
On kiva joskus huomata, ku tuommoist lapset, alakouikäiset lapset aivastaa hihansa,
ja olen silloin monta kertaa äidille ja lapselle itselleen kiitellu,
huomauttanut, että kuinka hienosti hoidetaan tämä homma,
että aikuisetkaan ei paljon enää muista tätä korona-ajan jälkeen,
että nyt pieniä muistutuksia radiosta, kansanradion puolelta,
ja mielellään myös terveydenhuoltoihmisten puolelta,
että hihanyskiminen on melkein paras ja varmin keino sitten kuitenkin,
kuin syvä kevättä kaikille. Kiitos.
Ei.
Mekkulimuori täällä tervee.
Kaikille niille, jotka haluavat lakeja ja määräyksiä.
Minäpä kerroin teille judun.
Minnen poltää tupakkiva, enkä ryypi viinaksiva,
enkä käytä huomehiva, taikka irtoseksivä.
Minnen tarptee määräyksivä, koska en halua mörkkyvä,
vaan vapaus on mun herkkuva.
Tupakkiva, viinaksiva, seksivä, ne on orkien herkkuva.
Vapaus on mun herkkuva, ja myrkylle näytän viemärivä.
Hyvä tiii, kaikki määräykset ja myrkyt. Hei vaan.
Hövää päivää täältä vain matkusteli, ja olis pikkuisen huolia kerrottavana seuraaville matkustajille teitä petty samalla lailla, kun meikäläinen on pettynyt,
näin reikan saaristoon, roodokseen, reettalle ja kyprokselle.
Semmonen juttu oli, että vessassa ei saa käyttää vessapaperia ollenkaan, laittaa ensinnäkään niinkö pyttyyn,
se pitää laittaa laatikkoon, joko on vessan pyntyn sivus oleva laatikko.
Sivooja, puistaa ne pois sitten, ja kauhea haju on siellä vessassa.
Mut meikäläinen teki sillalalla roodoksella, että mä tein tortut, teinut pussi, ja löin sinne ja nakkasin sen laatikon käytävään,
tulihan siitä huukkasanomista, näin, mutta…
Ja sitten paras saaristo, missä on käynyt, ni on Sisilia, tuota, ja…
niinkö nää Ran-Kanarion saaristot suosittelen, mutta reikan saaristoja en suosittelen misään tapauksessa,
roodoksella, kun oli nyt viime toukokuussa, ni se oli semmoisia hyttysiä, niitä ei ollut lapisakaan.
Tapa… aivan herneenkokoisia patteja tuli ihonko, tuota, ni… ne pistivät, ja… eikä mitä, ja kissat oli, tuota, ni… pitkin, tuota, ni…
niitä hyllyjä käveleskeli siellä niitä, erittäin epäsiisti, erittäin epäsiisti, en suosittele roodosta kenellekään.
Ei mitää muuta, kun se morosi.